all right guys bang bang I thought we'd
do a quick conversation with will uh
let's start with Bitcoin transactions
absolutely exploding over the last
couple of weeks what's going on yeah for
sure we've seen bitcoin's transaction
count reaching all-time high so Bitcoins
the Bitcoin network is now settling more
transactions than ever before uh the
question is what's driving this uh
frankly it's it's not people viewing
Bitcoin as a safe haven asset or you
know that may be playing a partial role
in it but it's really been the rise of
ordinals we've seen ordinals uh
inscriptions absolutely absolutely
explode over the last few weeks uh
ordinals have now generated over 7.6
million dollars in transaction fees for
the Bitcoin Network what exactly is an
ordinal an ordinal is an on-chain
inscription that essentially is based
off of a numeric uh system that applies
a number to every single Satoshi so
Satoshi is if you break down Bitcoin
it's the most divisible unit of a
Bitcoin so there's a hundred million
satoshi's in every Bitcoin uh what
ordinals do is essentially attach a
numbering system to every single Satoshi
and you can inscribe things like text
images Etc uh and so of course ordinals
primarily are just you know speculative
vehicle for people to gamble on very
similar to nfts on ethereum
um but they've absolutely exploded over
the last few weeks we've seen new
projects come out as well as exchanges
actually supporting the transactional
activity around ordinals why are people
putting Wizards everywhere that's all I
see on Twitter is that like one of the
memes that's kind of getting inscribed
into these uh satoshi's yeah that's one
of the more popular uh ordinals projects
that's taken off that was led by a Udi
and Eric Wall uh I think it's they're
trolling the kind of Bitcoin maximalist
Community a little bit
um but but yeah that's been one of the
the projects that's uh gotten some steam
got it now I understand why there's so
much debate over those two things
um so transactions are exploding higher
we also have seen hash rate just hit a
new all-time high uh I think that it's
the largest five-day increase in hash
rate what's driving that yeah so when
you think about ordinals again it's it's
driving a lot of transactional activity
on chain as we just mentioned when you
think about what that means for for
minors and transaction fees
um as you have more demand to use the
network there's an increased amount of
fees that individuals have to give to
minors to incentivize them to include
their transaction in a block so we've
seen that obviously reflected in
transaction count but we've also seen
the mempool the most full that it's been
since the FTX collapse which is
essentially again the backlog of
transactions and we all we've also seen
that translated to transaction fees
themselves so Bitcoin Network
transaction fees are now the highest
that they've been since July of 2021 and
so for minors it's a very positive thing
because they have more Revenue that
they're bringing in through transaction
fees I think it's also worth mentioning
that if ordinals aren't just a flash in
the pan and you know we see that this
trend continue
um you know given that we're in a bear
market and transactional activity is
this High uh if it's to sustain this
current Trend into you know kind of the
next multi-year Bull Run for BTC uh you
could see you know transaction fees
being extremely high uh and you know
pair that with some of the you know work
that people like Jack mahlers and strike
are doing or David Marcus and Light
spark are doing around
um you know kind of building out
lightning applications and building out
very Sleek user interfaces to interact
with lightning I think it actually sets
up a really interesting uh setup for the
lightning Network and and individuals to
move from using bitcoin's base chain to
actually adopting lightning is that
layer to to be able to transact without
you know very large fees on the base
chain when you see
um kind of all of those uh fees flowing
do you have any Viewpoint as to will
they grow to double or triple is it some
limiting factor like how should we think
about fee growth and is that positive
for the network or actually if there's
too many transactions and the fees get
too high is that a negative thing yeah
it's a great question so it kind of
depends how you want to frame it it's a
positive thing for miners because
they're bringing in more Revenue but
it's a negative thing for kind of the
the average retail user of the Bitcoin
base chain but again you know if we have
more applications built around lightning
that are easy to use for for the
individual user
um you know that should move those users
to the layer two and allows Bitcoin to
scale so it kind of depends the
perspective of who you're kind of asking
the question from got it um let's talk
about the four-year having cycle you uh
and the res reflexivity research team
did this huge deep dive on the four-year
having Cycles what did you find out yeah
for sure I think there's a couple points
that we can kind of break down
um the first one we kind of segmented
the report out into a few different
subtopics uh we looked at some kind of
macroeconomic factors um some of the
Bitcoin native factors and then what I
call kind of Behavioral Dynamics and
then kind of touched on miners briefly
as well
um first when we think about what is the
four-year cycle for anyone that's been
in the you know digital asset space for
for a long period of time I was very
familiar with this concept of the the
four-year cycle but for anyone who isn't
um you know oftentimes you'll hear you
know crypto Market commentators or
Market participants ask you how many
cycles have you been around for uh and
this is referring to what's at least
historically taken place as this kind of
four-year cycle that uh revolves around
Bitcoin Supply having and so the supply
having is when Bitcoin Supply issuance
gets cut in half uh the first one was in
2012 then 2016 uh May of 2020 and then
the upcoming spy having will be sometime
in late q1 early Q2 of 2024 and so
historically what this has indicated is
that when you have kind of this
imbalance of supply and demand you have
a decline in the amount of new Supply
coming onto the market even if demand
stays the same you should theoretically
have an upwards drift in price and so we
included a chart in the in the report
basically showing the 90-day change in
issuance relative to the the trailing uh
trend of issuance to show kind of that
apply quote-unquote Supply shock
um but what you when you compare that to
the overall circulating Supply you see
that that having effect actually
diminishes over time so a way to think
of this
I don't take baths anymore I don't think
I've taken a bath since I was five years
old if you're sitting in a bath and you
press your hand down on you know on the
bath water create a massive Ripple
throughout the entire bath
um if you were to apply that same
pressure in a lake It's Not Really Gonna
the Ripple's Not Gonna Go Far and if you
were to apply that same force in the
ocean it's not going to do anything so
you know my point in How to bring that
into to applying that to the Spy havings
is that you're applying the same
quote-unquote Supply shock or or impulse
but the overall pool of circulating
Supply is larger over time and therefore
there's a diminishing effect of of the
supply having on the overall market and
so that in itself in terms of driving
the cyclicality of Bitcoin has had a
diminishing effect when we look at some
of the kind of Behavioral Dynamics
there's a couple things that we looked
at the primarily the primary uh piece of
information that we looked at was this
idea of gauging profitability which we
used we used to gauge through on-chain
metrics which are essentially looking at
bitcoin's economics and so we can look
at things like how much unrealized or
also realized profit or loss the market
is is in uh what I mean by that is we
can look at the last time that all coins
moved on chain uh look at the mar you
know current marginal trading price that
bitcoin's trading at and compare the two
so we can see you know is the market in
a state of a massive amount of
unrealized profit if that's the case
there's a large likelihood that those
individuals are going to look to realize
some of that profit conversely when
we're in the bear Market there's a large
amount of realized losses especially uh
if we adjust it for market cap to get a
kind of relative view to historical bear
markets we can see that okay there's a
large amount of capitulation
capitulation is a kind of behavior that
historically marks the bottom of Cycles
in all markets including Bitcoin so
that's one of the most important pieces
of information we included a couple
different data points including Soper
net unrealized profit loss realize
profit loss all in the report and then
we also talked about the concept of
minors so we briefly touched on them uh
when we when we mentioned transactional
activity miners have a diminishing
effect on the overall Market over time
part of that is because of the supply
issuance so minor Revenue as a
percentage of overall circulating Supply
continues to decline and also when we
look at minor balances as a percentage
of overall circulating Supply that
continues to decline as well so
therefore they have a diminishing effect
on the overall you know implications for
bitcoin's Price action and then the last
piece that we looked at again was the
macroeconomic factors try to keep the
piece relatively Bitcoin Centric
um but I picked kind of two data points
that we're worth looking at one is ISM
and so what we're looking at here is
essentially a a survey of all
manufacturing economic pieces of
information Bitcoin has historically had
a very high correlation to ism
oh you have these very brief periods of
kind of decoration
um we saw this I believe in 2012 uh late
2018 before the the 2019 run up and
recently we've kind of seen this uh
decoupling of of continued decline in
ISM while Bitcoins continue to tick up
over the last few months uh what does
that indicate uh the reason for those
kind of decoupling or periods of
divergences is because whenever you have
a sharp economic decline
um the FED steps in with liquidity to
kind of counteract that economic decline
um and so I think it's kind of a
reflection of the sentiment of Market
participants in terms of thinking that
we've kind of reached Max hawkishness
for lack of a better term and with
monetary policy and people you know
being forward-looking in the market or
viewing Bitcoin as kind of a gauge for
that for that uh kind of pivot in
monetary policy over the next eight 12
months uh and then the other macro
economic metric that we included was the
dxy which is the dollar Index so it
looks at the dollar measured against
other major Fiat currencies specifically
in the in the piece we looked at the
year over year change so what's the
measure of of the Dixie today relative
to what it was a year ago today and we
can see that Bitcoin has historically
traded again with a very high
correlation to this and as you'll see in
the report the year-over-year change in
the dxy continues to decline uh which if
that Trend continues should be a
positive thing for BTC what is your
expectation with what will happen during
the next Bitcoin having
um yeah it's a very interesting question
um I think it depends what kind of time
frame you're talking about I think
locally you need to kind of watch how
people are positioned heading into the
having I think this is something we
mentioned on a previous episode that
we've done on the having but you know I
think it's important in markets to
understand it's not always about the
outright uh bullishness or bearishness
of an event it's you know how bullish or
how bearish or how positive or how
negative is this event relative to the
Market's expectations
um so you could have you know very
positive event but if it's not as
positive as the Market's expecting it to
be you could actually see a negative
reaction from the market because they're
over positioned too positively
um so I think that's something that I
would watch heading into the having this
is something that took place at the
beginning of 2020 uh we saw in the
derivatives data that you know we saw
things like funding rates absolutely
jacked like 200 APR heading into the
having so essentially everyone was
getting leveraged long expecting or kind
of front running the positive price
appreciation after you know following
the having and then they got wiped out
after after the covid crash that's
something that I would watch for kind of
locally but I think from a narrative
perspective alone it's very interesting
you've kind of got a stark contrast and
you know you very eloquently describe
this on CNBC last night of you know
you've got people debating you know what
this group of individuals is going to do
with monetary policy and there's a large
degree of of drone Powell basically
trying to go on a campaign to to reclaim
his credibility after calling inflation
transitory
um you know at the end of 2020 into 2021
and now it appears that he's kind of
overshooting to the downside uh with
tightening monetary policy
at the same time we've got you know a
programmatic monetary policy with
Bitcoin we know exactly you know what
the supply issuance of BTC is going to
be uh whenever they're having takes
place you know at the end of q1 early Q2
of next year so I think from a narrative
kind of perspective alone it's a it's a
it's a really interesting kind of
contrast if you've got all these Banks
blowing up meanwhile
um you know Bitcoin although you know
your price volatility uh Bitcoin really
is certainty and stability and in an
uncertain world uh because of the fact
that it's you know completely driven by
code and not you know human decisions
which are bound to to make mistakes with
monetary policy last thing I want to
talk about is I see all over the
Internet frogs I keep seeing them what
the hell is Pepe what are people talking
about this my general take is like all
this stuff ends up being super hyped up
and then it's absolute nonsense does it
have anything to do with Bitcoin is it
just a meme coin what is going on yeah
Pepe is an interesting one it's a it's a
meme that's been very ingrained into the
Bitcoin and crypto Community for for
years uh I'd be lying if I said that uh
I had a bag of Bitcoin I guess you know
Pomp and I we should have hedged our uh
you know our regional Bank stocks with
our Pepe coin and that's I guess the new
Safe Haven asset for for Global macro
economic investors
um but yeah yeah it's basically just one
of those meme tokens very similar to
Dojo it's just a meme token has nothing
to do with like the original nfts that
were on bitcoin or any of that type of
stuff it's literally just a meme token
that's trying to take over the meme
that's been around the Bitcoin committee
for a long time yeah pretty much and now
I saw this morning that uh binance is
listing it on on their exchange and so
uh I would say be very careful you know
obviously uh you know these are very
high risk uh assets I'm not I'm not
advocating anyone to buy it but I would
say definitely don't short this thing
either uh I think you know the
degeneracy uh can kind of Outlast uh you
as there's you know saying in markets um
the market can stay irrational longer
than you can remain solvent so I would
say be very careful trying to trying to
short this thing Jesus Christ all right
thank you so much for doing this we'll
definitely do it again in the future
thanks